plus de deux cents ans après sa mort
près de smolensk le général que d'un
edel de napoléon s'envole enfin vers sa
patrie mais la politique c'est tout de
même l'ailé de cet événement historique
il était prévu que le général français
rejoigne son ami souverain aux invalides
lors d'une cérémonie d'hommage en
présence de vladimir poutine emmanuel
macron le 5 mai le jour du bicentenaire
de la mort de napoléon
or le rapatriement de la dépouille
retrouvée en 2019 a été d'abord reporté
pour des raisons sanitaires ensuite
classé la france n'ayant pas dépenser un
centime pour toute l'opération c'est un
oligarque russe qui a prêté son avion à
la fondation pour le développement des
initiatives historique franco-russe à
l'origine de la découverte archéologique
pour transporter les restes du général
gudin en france ça a été complètement
annulé au mois d'avril l'année dernière
mais le dossier a même pas été gelés il
a été classé donc ça veut dire que dudin
devaient être enterrés ici en russie et
ce qui donc j'ai pris la décision moi
même pas de le rapatrier à travers
énormément de loin on vous doutez bien
un très grand protocole avec la famille
est de trouver un avion pour pouvoir le
rapatrier mais maintenant qu'on leur
amène et que l'elysée a réagi et qu'on
aura une ministre à l'arrivée tout est
possible moi j'ai quelques informations
bien sûr mais qui élit le président de
la dîmière poutine ça je sais pas ça
sera maintenant de la nouvelle politique
de nouvelle diplomatie ça me concerne
qu'une fois que j'ai rendu le corps
maintenant le corps appartient à la
france l'est et en russie maintenant il
va appartenir à la france maintenant
c'est au président de la république de
décider s'il veut inviter le président
poutine
mais dans tous les cas le corps sera en
france et il sera honoré comme il comme
il le mérite
je peux que féliciter quand même le
président de la république d'avoir réagi
il ya deux jours est de vouloir faire
quelque chose à l'arrivée ça va être je
pense grandiose maintenant mais jusque
maintenant je n'ai pas à remercier
puisqu'on a fait tout seul malgré les
hésitations des autorités françaises le
général du daim recevra les honneurs qui
lui était due en france en russie déjà
c'est l'ambassadeur de france qui s'est
dit ému de l'événement je voulais vous
dire simplement que c'était un moment un
moment très très émouvant
le général gudin retrouve sa famille
retrouve la terre de france
il s'est battu dans la grande armée il a
perdu la vie ici il a été retrouvé grâce
à des recherches archéologiques franco
franco-russe donc c'est un grand moment
qui montre aussi cette histoire partagée
que nous avons entre la russie et la et
la france côté russe on se félicite du
symbole que représente le rapatriement
de la dépouille du général que d'un en
france au moment de réconciliation entre
les deux pays
pour moi cet événement est vraiment un
vrai rayon du soleil aujourd'hui parce
que cet événement est à la fois
diplomatique politique culturelle et
historique
donc c'est un événement
historique qui peut être entre sur les
pages des livres d'histoire dans le
climat politique actuel et les relations
franco-russes plus que vos froid 10 ans
moment d'unité ne serait pas à négliger